foreign
[Music]
it's a beautiful
anymore
rainforest Tipping Point so all the
little red dots this is all law reset
deforestation and
closer to
to understand how they operate I'll
travel to a violent Frontier
what's fueling the multi-billion dollar
trade for illegal Timber
house a global Gold Rush wreaking havoc
on the jungle he said it could end up in
a gold ring just like mine
what are the stakes for our planets I
think it makes sense to think about the
Amazon as a canary in the coal mine yeah
if we can't save it we're doomed
[Music]
a
500 miles from the mouth of the Amazon
where a gold rush feeling hangs in the
air
so as soon as you get here you get a
sense that this whole town is geared
towards exploiting the Amazon you can
see it everywhere there's gold shops
there's places selling chainsaws and
even the local mayor the former
goldminer
while it might not surprise you that
illegal logging is a major factor in
deforestation gold mining is equally
malicious
I've come to this region where nearly 30
tons of gold are extracted illegally
every year as the first step on my
mission to understand how criminal
networks are decimating the Amazon okay
we're here
but how do I actually make my way into
the Amazon's underworld
a contact I've set up a meeting with a
driver who works for local Prospectors
[Music]
clearly this is not the answer I'm
looking for
but what I've learned from these
situations is to never take the first no
as the final answer
and to keep buying drinks
[Music]
after a few rounds the driver's tune has
changed
he now says he might be able to get me
into a mine he knows deep me Amazon
jungle
but there's a catchers
so thanks to my new drinking buddy the
next morning I find myself on one of the
Amazon's Infamous small planes
thank you
[Music]
looking out the window while trying not
to think about going down in a ball of
flames I'm struck by the immensity of
the Amazon
but in 2020 an area the size of
345 Manhattans was wiped out
and in Brazil up to 94 percent of that
deforestation can be considered illegal
all these brown dots that you feel these
clearings in the jungle that's all the
illegal gold mines
so who are the criminals responsible for
this destruction
and why is gold mining so devastating to
the rainforest
I'm hoping to find out
a Runway made out of dirt
I can't tell you where I'm headed it's
an agreement I made last night with the
driver so that's our guys waiting for us
over there their contacts were taking us
to the mind
okay seriously cameras cameras down
you already asked not to film as we
arrived
but I can tell you this it's always a
little nerve-wracking getting in a car
with a masked man someone I don't know
if I can trust me
yes
the masked man who I'll be calling Allah
says he's taking me to
four gold mines deep in the rain forest
assistant
Alan tells me that other illegal
Prospectors in the area know I'm here
and we need to be on guard
they almost prevented us from even
landing and so he's saying that uh
people are just super scared here
in Brazil illegal gold mining is
estimated to bring in more than a
billion dollars a year
while gold trafficking is less
widespread than login it can leave
permanent scars
loggers often Harvest valuable treats
and leave the rest
miners however slash everything in their
path wow
surrounded by the jungle here it's just
a big clearing
right in the middle of the rainforest
this is pretty big much bigger than I
expected
at the belly of a man-made crater miners
toil away in the mud stripping back
layer after layer averts look marking us
there's more tortoise foreign
[Music]
gold mines are a breeding ground for
malaria and the pace is furious
[Music]
it's crazy to think that all of this has
been done in just one week they just
started working in this area a week ago
and you can see how much of it is
already cleared out
[Music]
deforestation from illegal gold mining
has increased by more than 90 percent in
recent years and are insatiable thirst
for the precious metal threatens to make
the situation even worse
tech companies consume hundreds of tons
of gold a year pure gold is used in
every smartphone where are the products
that are being produced in the Amazon
going they're coming here to the US
they're going to Europe these massive
corporations could decide to really
trace the supply chains but they're
choosing not to
the murky supply chain ensures that
dirty gold finds its way into the market
much as blood diamonds do
and in Brazil dirty gold has added
significance oh it's Mercury that they
were putting in I don't think
so he just has this Mercury and the gold
sort of combines with the Mercury and
that's how they look and find gold here
despite what Alan says Mercury leaves
Rivers poisoned the pollution can spread
hundreds of miles Downstream
you see these little specks the yellow
specks are the gold and these little
sort of silver balls that's the gold
covered in Mercury
Allah then takes the unrefined gold to a
dealer one who doesn't ask too many
questions
a gold ring just like mine
foreign
[Music]
are simply left to their own devices the
Amazon will continue to face a dark
future
and in many cases they actually have
very little to show for it
sometimes they only get 70 to 80 grams
of gold out of an area like this so all
this work was almost for nothing that
amount means only a few thousand dollars
for a week of work for Allah and his two
dozen workers
traffickers in the Amazon are playing a
high stakes game
and more times than not they're losing
this man is an inside source from ibama
Brazil's Environmental Protection Agency
is
okay
um
my source from ibama says that at the
moment his agency is losing the battle
with the Amazon Mafia
is
because
is and corruption in Brazil allows
international criminal organizations to
reap the benefits
but getting Black Market Commodities out
of the country relies on one key player
the middleman
Lego
this dealer buys gold from mines all
over the Amazon Bayside
he has enough he melts it and sells it
to international buyers
gold laundering the mixing of legal and
illegal gold nearly ensures that
trafficked gold finds its way into the
market these massive corporations will
turn a blind eye to the mixing of
illegally obtained materials with
legally obtained materials and then they
can take the certificate of authenticity
for the legally obtained stuff and slap
it on the whole batch and say okay we're
good and because of this 90 of Fortune
500 companies that invest in Golds can
be linked to Illegal Minds in Latin
America is
positive
[Music]
Pixies
foreign
fights of Amazon
after seeing the effects of gold mining
firsthand I'm going deeper into the
Amazon hoping to find those responsible
for deforestations original sin the
first step in deforestation in the
Amazon is usually illegal logging
so there are a few types of wood in the
Amazon that are really valuable on the
international market things like
mahogany
loggers will go in they'll cut down
those valuable trees and then they will
just chop down all the rest and then
burn them then when the land is cleared
from the fires that can serve as cattle
pastures
shockingly an estimated 50 percent of
logging in Brazil is illegal
and United States is one of the biggest
importance of trafficked wood from the
Amazon
the high stakes have made the jungle a
violent place
money
on the edge of the Amazon's protected
areas lies a small settlement
boy
I've traveled here to understand what
can happen to you when you go up against
the Amazon Mafia
[Music]
run a small organic farm surrounded by
old growth Timber
nearly all the forests are joining their
property have been cut down in recent
years
the Paredes have managed to protect and
plant new trees on their farm and
they've reported illegal activity to the
authorities
which has made them a target of local
criminals
one day after returning to their house
the couple found a local logging boss
waiting for them
accompanied by a squad of armed men
foreign
of the world's biodiversity and so can
you imagine when somebody chops down a
tremendous area that burns for 10 days
Dorothy Stang was an American nun who
campaigned for 30 years to stop illegal
loggers in the Amazon
in 2005 while walking in the jungle she
was murdered with six shots fired at
close range
stang's murder is far from an isolated
incident more than 1 700 people have
been killed in land conflicts since
2000.
and in this part of the world where
impunity Reigns only 10 percent of the
murders were brought to Justice
following the threats from the local
logging boss the parade is awoke one
morning to find that someone had crept
onto their Farm
[Music]
fudge
leaving a terrifying warning
[Music]
is
foreign
ERS continue to receive death threats
but they refused to let the criminals
have their way
thank you
again
foreign
my source says the situation got even
more dire after the 2018 election of
Brazil's president
it is a fallacy that the Amazon is a
Heritage of humanity and it is also a
mistake to say it is the lungs of the
world certain countries are using these
fallacies and instead of helping have
started to attack with lies
when Jerry boltonaro was elected a lot
changed deforestation skyrocketed
there's been a massive roll back in
respect for indigenous rights and
bolsonaro has regularly in public
encouraged Amazon deforestation he's
encouraged the arsonist lighting a lot
of the fires and he's defamed a lot of
the indigenous leaders
when the head of state is encouraging
violence that sends a very clear message
according to observers his
administration has effectively given a
green light to those who want to destroy
the Amazon for profit
which critics say includes the most
powerful man in utaituba
at his Riverside Mansion I arrange a
meeting with the town's mayor valmid
climaco so Mariana
he's not shy about his past as a logger
and minor
according to climaco's own election
filings he's the subject of 45 Federal
Criminal citations but his trouble with
the law hasn't hurt his popularity
mayor climaco now owns cattle ranches
and Farms cleared from the rainforest
Industries responsible for millions of
Acres of deforestation is
Lego
was acquitted of some charges
though he still faces spending trials
for alleged environmental crimes dating
back to 2012.
however climaco doesn't think Mining and
logging are hurting the Amazon either
way
foreign
this is all a seductive argument for
those who stand to make huge profits
but it doesn't mesh with the reality
I've seen in my time here foreign
rather than debating the mayor on the
merits of inhaling Mercury fumes I want
to ask him about the slew of killings in
the region including Dorothy Stang the
American nun
content
is
with the help of the FBI Brazilian
authorities eventually convicted two
ranchers of orchestrating Dorothy
stang's murder
Ed
climaco's own property lies alongside
the ancestral territory of the munduruku
indigenous tribe for climaco letting
them manage the land would be the real
travesty
a possibility
[Music]
despite what mayor climaco says Brazil's
indigenous people are now some of the
most courageous Defenders of the Amazon
still on the search for illegal loggers
I'm going on patrol with members of the
mundaroku indigenous tribe we've been
going in further and further in for over
an hour now
they're actually looking for signs but
there's been illegal activity in this
area
I'm on patrol with the moon trial trying
to catch illegal authors in the act all
these cut branches that you see are
clear signs that there's been some sort
of illegal activity usually it's illegal
loggers that come here and start cutting
the branches so they can go through
deeper into the jungle look there okay
this is all evidence that the illegal
loggers have been here you can see a
whole structure over there
this Camp has been set up in the short
time since the mundruko last went on
patrol
s plans to confront the loggers and
force them out of mundruku territory is
the bullet case 38 cows
Brazil's indigenous people have
increasingly come under violent attacks
spices
foreign
even with the chance of an armed
encounter Chief Juarez says it's time to
move forward they've heard that there's
people actually cutting down trees about
an hour from here so he says we should
keep going we'll try to go as far as we
can
as we proceed deeper and deeper into the
rainforest it's hard not to feel
completely exposed
criminals could be behind any Bend of
the river
after another hour on the water the
chief stops our boat the loggers have
clearly been here
yeah
[Music]
they come in with chainsaws look for
trees like this and they left it behind
because they realized it was actually
going to fall into the river
s Amazon
even with fresh evidence of their work
the Chief says the criminals have
slipped away
[Applause]
[Music]
but two days later I get a new lead
after dozens of calls I finally receive
a promising message from a local contact
and a former illegal logger
to the axis I've been working on for
months
but it's in an area with one of Brazil's
highest murder rates
that'll be miles and miles from help if
anything goes wrong
and as I head out to an undisclosed
location I have no idea what or who I
might find
okay this is it
hunting guys
do it
the boss meets me at the access road and
says we need to hurry onto the truck so
we're not spotted okay so we go in the
back of the truck
[Applause]
thank you
it's not an accident that this is a
bumpy ride loggers cut narrow roads
hidden under the forest canopy to throw
off aerial surveillance
we just got stuck
the big truck got stuck
I have no idea how they know
the truck isn't going anywhere
on top of that we're subtly alone
the guy who's taking us in just left
so we're stuck here it's super muddy and
wet everywhere
stranded in the middle of the Jungle
with potentially violent criminals
operating in the area
and there's nothing to do but wait
[Music]
and we're stuck here
just us and a big illegal logging truck
for 30 minutes are contact returns and
he's got some heavy equipment with him
the rainy season is normally a quiet
time of the year for the illegal timber
tree because of the difficulty reaching
the jungle but these loggers seem to be
working harder than ever
[Music]
but I mean it's incredible it's just in
the middle of this thick thick piece of
jungle and there's just this clearing
and this is what they've done they've
just cleared this all out
the loggers tell me that just yesterday
a member of another crew was killed
during the part of the process I'm
watching now
they're saying it's incredibly dangerous
to be behind where the log is going up
because it's common that the cables
break and it will fall on so a lot of
people have been injured and and killed
when this happens they're just these
like two cables that are pulling the log
up to the truck
this is all super sketchy I mean they're
Barefoot you know they're doing all of
this a lot of them are barefoot
it may not be a high-tech operation
but they work fast and efficiently
so they've done all this damage that you
see here all this clearing in just the
last two weeks
[Music]
is
I think
lagers usually take pains to avoid being
caught ebama raids mean crippling fines
and destroyed equipment
but insiders say the illegal Timber
trade is operating more openly than in
years past
they say they're going to cut down
another tree right now
the men tell me how they clear the most
valuable trees first and are quick to
spot which ones to cut next
[Music]
yeah so they're saying that they think
it's going to fall that way but when it
does when it cracks that a lot of sort
of debris oh my God you can did you hear
that did you hear that so that's it when
you fear that first crack
that means the tree is falling it's
slowly falling and then you just
watch out watch out
wow I mean it's insane you can feel the
you can hear the cracks incredibly loud
and then you can feel the whole sort of
uh ground shake
knowing that these trees could soon end
up in a wood floor or backyard deck
somewhere in the U.S it's hard to
stomach
okay let's go see that he's saying we
can go and see it the fallen tree
wow yeah
um
it's not even worth anything which makes
this whole thing even more depressing I
mean all of this and wasted for for
nothing
seeing this pointless destruction
reminds me of what I witnessed at the
Gold Mine the Amazon is being ravaged
based on false hopes by those in the
trenches
if there's one thing I've learned from
reporting on the world's black markets
it's that the people who are getting
their hands dirty often feel like they
have no other choice
criminals on the Bottom Rung of the
Shadow economy say they're simply trying
to survived foreign
holding those accountable for the
murders in the Amazon is seemingly an
impossible task
it's no surprise that so many of those
killings have gone unpunished
I may never come face to face with those
at the top but I have one last way to
expose the Amazon Mafia
I'm going to follow the timber
[Music]
under the cover of night the logs I saw
being cut down in the Amazon earlier are
transported here to this illegal sawmill
I still want to understand what happens
to Timber illegally harvested in the
Amazon
and if this wood will soon end up in the
hands of U.S consumers
but nobody at the Mill wants to talk
foreign
[Music]
suddenly I'm told it's time for us to
stop filming
shipment of cut boards is heading out
and you've been explicitly warned not to
follow
it's frustrating to me without tracking
this wood any farther
but I already know where a lot of it is
headed
[Music]
sometimes it's a bit of a reveal
when you look at a shipment like this
and you open it up it takes your breath
away for a second
to be like wow that's not what I was
expecting
and you realize how big some of the wood
is you do step back and you put that in
perspective how old was that tree
at a warehouse near the Port of Houston
Agents from U.S Customs and Border
Protection are inspecting a new shipment
from Latin America
some of the wood today is Raising red
flags when we look at the documents the
wood states that it's a certain age when
we come here and physically look at the
wood it looks much older than what's on
the documents therefore it probably
didn't come from the mill it's on the
paperwork and then we're going to look
further into that wood
as one of the largest Timber importers
in the world the US is a prime target
for Black Market organizations
smuggling trees from the Amazon is a
federal crime in violation of the Lacy
Act
we attempt to catch everything that
comes our way
due to the pure volume of stuff like
that most likely stuff does make it
through but our attempt is to catch
everything entering this country
one estimate now puts the worldwide
trade for illegal Timber as high as
152 billion dollars
we are seeing a larger increase in
shipments coming out of the Amazon than
previous years so the problem isn't
going away it's only increasing
accused
there's so much responsibility that we
have to address our own contributions to
the climate crisis
so many of the companies that are based
here are buying and selling the very
products that are produced in deforested
parts of the rainforest it comes down to
how important is it and how important
are we insisting that it be I think it
makes sense to think about the Amazon as
as a canary in the coal mine in the
sense that if we can't save it
we're doomed
all these little red dots that are a lot
of them all represent deforestation that
has happened in just the last five years
exactly 20 percent of the Amazon
rainforce is already deforced so we
reached that level if we keep
deforesting we may reach a Tipping Point
so the death of the Amazon has been on
yes that's a possible scenario
Carlos Sosa is a researcher for an
environmental non-profit called Amazon
through satellite technology they're
able to monitor deforestation on a micro
level including the illegal logging site
I witnessed myself
it's crazy to think that it looked so
massive at the time and now to think
that it's just probably a little tiny
tiny tiny little dot that's why it's so
important to have a real real-time
person on it right because you can see
the the most active
areas and go stop to stop rhetorically
but we have the data is alarming Dr
Susan says it should be a wake-up call
for the entire world so does that mean
that this is it where it's completely
hopeless there's nothing we can do about
it there is hope
first we have to make sure that they're
not purchasing anything from the Amazon
that I think it's too illegal
deforestation and then we need more
International awareness about the
problem to convince the Brazil to change
this path to destruction
[Music]
good news
and there are still those on the ground
fighting against deforestation
looking at the Amazon from high above
it's striking that there are these
islands of intact Forest
when you get closer you notice that many
of those areas are indigenous lands
before leaving the Amazon I returned to
one of those islands the munduruku
territory
I reunite with tribal leader and
activist Alessandra munduruku
tonight the village is having a meeting
to discuss how they can fight back
against a new bill proposed by the
bolsonaro government
the bill would open up mining in
protected areas like the munduruku
territory it
is
the Amazon's hundreds of indigenous
tribes have survived Conquest smallpox
enslavement and assimilation
and the future of our planet might
depend on them
standing in the way the Amazon Mafia
is
but for the munduruku stopping powerful
criminal networks alone is too much to
ask
foreign governments will have to supply
pressure
and consumers will have to investigate
where the products they buy come from
and if we are helping to protect the
Amazon or destroy it
[Music]